[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
مقتل حاكم ولايه بلغ شماليه افغانستان في
انفجار ضخم استهدف اجتماعا داخل مقره
هجوم صاروخي الروسي يستهدف عده مدن
اوكرانيه ويخرج محطه زابوريا عن الخدمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات اسرائيليه تمنع من دخول تل ابيب
وسيجي لقاءاته خارج المدينه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم بلده جامع جنوب
مخيم جنين وتقتل ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قتل داود مزمل حاكم
ولايه بل شمال افغانستان بانفجار داخل مقر
ادارته في مدينه مزار الشريف عاصمه
الولايه واسفل الانفجار ايضا عن سقوط عدد
من القتلى والمصابين وكان داوود مزمل
قيادي عسكري بارز في طالبان وله علاقه
قويه بالحرس الثوري الايراني وظهر في فيلم
الوثائقي لقناه حكوميه الايرانيه قبل
سنوات يتحدث عن قتاله ضد الامريكيين
متابعه هذا الموضوع ينضموا لنا في
الاستوديو الصحفي الافغاني احمد السيد
اهلا بك احمد معنا في هذه النشره بدايه
ماذا نعرف عن ملابسات هذا الانفجار ومن
الذي يمكن ان يكون مستفيدا منه في تقديرك
في البدايه اتوقع ان الانفجار الذي وقع
اليوم قد يكون تطلع به داعش بحكم
اختراقاتها المتكرره ومحاولات اغتيالات
للمسؤولين في طالبان وحتى البيتات
الدبلوماسيه الاجنبيه في افغانستان لكن
ملابسات الحادث حتى الان حسب المعلومات
الاوليه من احد مصادر في ولايه بلغ بين
الانفجار يستطاع الدخول الى داخل مقر حاكم
الولايه وقام بتفجير نفسي في اثناء
الاجتماع الاداري الذي كان يعقده حاكم
الولايه مزمل مبدئيا انه قد يتوقع ان الذي
قام بتفجير نفسها والانفجار او من
حتى الان هناك قد يكون شخص ما زرع قنبله
نفس المكان باعتقادي بان الشخص الذي قام
بالانفجار هو شخص يعمل في الشرطه ويعمل في
مقر الولايه وبحيث لن يستطيع الوصول الى
مقر الحاكم
بسهوله الا اذا لم يكن لديه يعني وسيله
للدخول الى ذلك المكان طيب يعني اصابع
الاتهام الان تشير الى داعش كما تفضل لكن
هذا الانفجار ايضا وهذا الهجوم ياتي في
وقت
التوتر بين قاده الطالبان انفسهم هناك
خلافات كبيره كما تشير بعد قليل الى وزير
الماليه وبين ايضا قائد طالبان او زعيم
طالبان هل يمكن ان يكون هذا العمل مدبرا
او او هو يعتبر فعلا داخليا بمعنى تصفيه
حسابات بين قاده طالبان امر ذلك في الوقت
الحالي تصل الامور الى هذا الحد لا يمكن
ان نستبعد هذه الموضوع انه قد يكون هناك
امر مدبر او لا ولكن حاكم كما ذكرتم بانه
مقرب من الحارس من الحرس الثوري الايراني
ولو علاقات قويه قد تكون هناك تصفيات يعني
الداخليه او حتى تصفيات تطلع بها داعش
بحكمه العلاقه بين داعش خراسان وايران او
الحرس الثوري بشكل عام فقد يعتقد بانه على
خلاف مع الحرس الثوري مع انه اقوى ثالث
حليف لايران في افغانستان او في حكومه
طالبان هو حاكم بلغ فاعتقادي حتى الان انه
لم تصل الامور بان تكون بشكل علني
التصفيات الداخليه بين قائد الطالبان ولكن
كشخص مثل
داود مزمل هو له علاقات قويه وله يعني رجل
خطير جدا من من نواحي الامنيه من نواحي
النفوذ من نواحي سيطرته على عمليات تهريب
المخدرات والاسلحه وبيعها
طيب اخي الاحصائيات المتوفيه لكم حول هذا
الانفجار والاصابات هل فقد اقتصرت على
الدائره المقربه من حاكم الولايه ام ان
هناك اصابات لاشخاص اخرون كانوا تريد ايضا
في هذا الاجتماع يتوقع يتقد احد المعلومات
قالوا بان احمد الله وثيق رئيس هيئه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في طالبان يتوقع بانه
اصيب خلال الانفجار حتى ولكن لم تظهر حتى
لنا الاعداد الرسميه واعداد اوليه حتى
لعدد القتلى والمصابين ومنهم اقتصرت حتى
ان طالبان اعلنوا قبل قليل فقط مقتل داوود
مزمل ولم يشير الى من كانوا معه في
الاجتماع من او من قتلى او مصابين فاعتقد
حتى الان موضوعك عمليه اغتيال داود مزمل
ورجل قيادي بارز وعسكري من كبار العسكريين
في طالبان من الذين صنعوا اسمهم خلال قتال
من القوات البريطانيه في عام 2003 في
هرمنت في مسقط راسه نهيب مثابه صدمه
لطالبان طالبان تصدم بهكذا خبر في اول مع
هذا اليوم اعتقد بان حتى سي هناك محاوله
تستتر على موضوع من قتل معه من اصيب معه
الى ان يصل الى ان سوف تشير المصادر او
تخرج تسريبات عن من كانوا متواجدين
افادت
بان ملا هدايه الله بدري وزير الماليه في
حكومه الحركه الطالبان قدم استقالته منصبه
بسبب خلافات مع زعيم الحركه هبه الله اخون
زاده وذكرت القناه الافغانيه المستقله
ذكرت ان مسؤولي الحركه رفضوا الرد على
اتصالات القناه للتعليق على الاستقاله
وبحسب التقرير فان بدري المنحدر من قندهار
معقل الحركه كان يسيطر على الموارد
الماليه لطالبه لسنوات عديده وكان مسؤولا
عن توفير المعدات العسكريه لمقاتليها
واصبح احد اقوى الشخصيات النافذه في صفوف
الحركه
نعود مره اخرى الى الصحفي احمد السيد احمد
هل استقال وزير الماليه ام اجبر على
الاستقاله في ظل الحديث عن خلافات بينه
وزعيم الحركه الطالبان باعتقاد انه اجبر
على الاستقاله للخلافات التي بينه وبين
زعيم طالبان كانت خلافات موارد ماليه او
الامور الماليه كان هدايه الله بدري
المعروف هو معروف بهداية الله بدر واسمه
الحقيقي اسحاق
او عفوا كل اغا اسحاق زيه هو كان من من
اوائل من اسسوا طالبنا زعيمها الملا عمر
ومن ثم كان يتولى مسؤوليه الموارد الماليه
خلال 20 عاما من قتال الحركه ضد القوات
الافغانيه والقوات الامريكيه
الخلافات باعتقاد بانه هي خلافات قائمه
على موارد ماليه على
الموارد الماليه امور ماليه لا اعتقد
بانها خلافات عقديه مثلا او خلافات فكريه
جيولوجيه لكن حتى الان طالبا لم
لم تقر بانه يستقال من منصبه او لا ولكن
باعتقادي سوف يتم الاعلان عن استقالته
قريبا خصوصا بان زعيم طالبان يحاول
التغيير داخل مجلس الوزراء الحركه لان
الحركه الان في الوقت الحالي هناك خلافات
وتوترات داخليه في مجلس الوزراء طالبان
طالبان يحاول هذا التغيير وسوف يوافق على
الاستقاله وسوف يعين شخص اخر مقرب منه
يتولى هذا الملك
قتاله ضد الامريكان طبعا هذه الصور سيدي
احمد قبل قليل وهي صور متداوله هل يمكن ان
تؤكد لنا شخصيه هذا الرجل وما هي ايضا
تداعيات مقتله على الوضع في افغانستان
ولكثره عامه
هو داود مزمل شخصيا داود مزمل تداعيات
مقتلوا ستكون كبيره على
الطالبان لانه رجل قيادي عسكري بارز كما
اخبرتك انه هو صنع اسمه من خلال قتاله
للقوات البريطانيه في 2003 من خلال
العمليات
الالغام التي كان يزرعها على الطريقه او
حتى الانفجار التفجيرات الانتحاريه التي
كان يرسل انتحارين الى القوات البريطانيه
ومعسكراتهم
فيما بعد في
استخدمته ايران في او فرضته في مناطق
الحدوديه معها في ليتولى مسؤوليه عمليه
تهريب المخدرات والاسلحه وحتى عمليه وصول
قاده الحرس الثوري الى افغانستان هذا
نتحدث عنه قبل سقوط الحكومه الافغانيه
يعني كان هو يتولى مسؤوليه التنقل قاده
الحرس الثوري داخل افغانستان وبين قيادات
طالبان بحكم انه مقرب منهم الامر الاخر
داود مزمل كان يتولى خلال فتره 2016 كان
يتولى
قتال داعش خراسان في افغانستان في 2016
تولى عمليه القتال ضد داعش في هولند هي
مسقط راسه والتي كان احد ابرز القيادين
المقربين واصدقائي المقربين عبد الرؤوف
خادم هو كان من مؤسسي تنظيم داعش في
افغانستان كانت هناك عمليات قتال بينهما
ومن ثم اخيرا تولى مسؤوليه انه يكون الى
في يتولى مسؤوليه القتال داعش في الولايات
الشماليه في افغانستان
بانه بالنسبه لطالبان خساره كبيره بالنسبه
للحرس الثوري الايراني خساره كبيره واذا
كانت داعش او اي جهه اخرى تبنت او نفذت
هذه العمليه سيكون بالنسبه لها احد
انجازاتها قتل داود مزمل نظره للثقه الذي
يمثله هذا الرجل في صفوف طالبان بهذا
القدر شكرا لك كنت معنا في الاستوديو اصبح
في الافغاني احمد السيد تحياتي احمد شكرا
لك
مشاهدينا الى اوكرانيا حيث وقعت انفجارات
في العاصمه كيف بعض ضربات مكثفه استهدفت
انحاء واسعه من اوكرانيا حيث شنت القوات
الروسيه 25 غاره جويه واثنين هجوما
صاروخيا على مدن عده بينها
بحسب هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه واعلن الجيش
الاوكراني عن اسقاط 15 صاروخا روسيا فوق
مدينتي
نتج عن هذا الهجوم الروسي مقتل خمسه اشخاص
واصابه عدد اخر
اعلنا المشغل الاوكراني في محطه زابوريجا
النوويه عن قطاع التيار الكهربائي عن
المحطه بعد ضربه روسيه والعمل حاليا
بمولدات الديزل واشار بيان لشركه هنرجو
اتوم الاوكرانيه الى انقطاع اخر خط اتصال
بين محطه للطاقه النوويه ونظام الطاقه
الاوكراني نتيجه الهجمات الصاروخيه من جهه
اخرى اتهمت سلطه الزابوريج لروسيا كياب
بقطع امدادات الكهرباء عن المحطه ووصفت
ذلك باستفزاز
بدوره ايضا مشاهدينا اعلن قائد قوات
السيطره على بلده توبوفو الواقعه في شمال
غرب باخب وذكر بيان لقوات فاغنر ان البلده
باتت بالكامل تحت سيطرتها بعد معارك باريا
ويعد ذلك اول تقدم للقوات الروسيه في
المحور الشمالي الغربي لمدينه بعد السيطره
على الجانب الشرقي
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا بك محمد هذه الضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه طارت كييف ايضا ما ابرز داعيتها
وخم مشاهداتك
نعم بالفعل يعني ليله امس عند الساعه
12:30 دوره سفارات الانذار في معظم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عندما
اقلعت حوالي عشر طائرات استراتيجيه من نوع
توي 95 وسبع طائرات تي 22 و 6 ايراد 31
التي تحمل صواريخ كينجال تم اطلاق 81
صاروخ ومسيره ايرانيه الصنع على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بينها ست صواريخ انجال وهذه
المره الاولى التي تطلق روسيا ست صواريخ
فنجان دفعه واحده باتجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بحسب تقديراته يعني
سلاح الجو الاوكراني تم اسقاط اكثر من 62
صاروخا ومسيره ايرانيه تصنع هذا كعدد
اجمالي تم اسقاطها والباقي اصاب عدد من
الاهداف في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف سقط في
سقط صاروخ
فيون سقط صاروخ كينجول كما يتداول وفيها
بعد اعلان بالامس كان هناك اعلان من
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان هناك خيار
ان تكون وتسعى الامم المتحده ان تكون
منطقه
هي منطقه منزوعه السلاح لا وجود عسكري
فيها لا من الجانب الاوكراني ولا من
الجانب الروسي طيب الاداره العسكريه محمد
تتحدث عن ان 40 في المئه من سكان البلاد
قد حرموا بناء الكهرباء هل مازال
الكهرباء منقطعا حتى هذه اللحظه لا لا وقت
اطلاق الصواريخ اعلنت وزاره الطوارئ
الاوكرانيه عن اطفاء طارق لشبكه التيار
الكهربائي وهذه يعني اعتدنا اثناء قيام
روسيا بضربات صاروخيه واسعه المدى يتم
اطفاء التيار الكهربائي في المنطقه التي
انا يعني هنا عند الساعه الواحده صباحا تم
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وعند الثامنه
صباحا عاد التيار الكهربائي بشكل طبيعي
بحسب ما يتداول هناك 15% من مدينه كيف
الان دون كهرباء ومياه بسبب يعني استهداف
احد احدى المنشات الطاقه الكهربائيه وتعمل
فرق الصيانه كما قال في
عمله كيف تعمل فرق الصيانه على معالجه
يعني هذه الضربات لكن مدينه خاركوف
بالكامل كما يتداول انقطع التيار
الكهربائي والمياه عن تلك المدينه بعد
استهداف محطتي للطاقه في تلك المنطقه
بصوريات كبيره جدا لهذه الغارات وهنا سؤال
حول مدى استعدادات الجيش الاوكراني للتصدي
مثل هذه الغارات كيف يقيم ايضا القاده او
الخبراء العسكريون قدراتك في التصدي لهذه
الغارات الصاروخيه الروسيه حاليا وفي
مستقبلا ايضا
يعني تم اطلاق حوالي 80 صاروخا وبحسب ما
يتداول استطاعت الدفاعات الجويه اسقاط
حوالي 60 يعني يمكن القول 20 الى 30% لم
تستطع او يمكن 70 الى 80% استطاعت
الدفاعات الجويه اسقاط يعني الضربات
الصاروخيه ولهذا كان يطالب الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير وحتى قائد او وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
بضروره تزويد اوكرانيا بالمزيد من انظمه
الدفاع الجويه وبحسب مصادر خاصه لنا في
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالوا ان تشكيله
اطلاق الصواريخ كانت مختلفه اليوم كانت
مختلفه عن السابق خاصه ان تم اطلاق ست
صواريخ كنجول من عده يعني اختلاف يعني
اماكن مختلفه او اتجاهات مختلفه لذلك يعني
منظومات الدفاع الاوكرانيه استطاعت اسقاط
صاروخ او صاروخين كنجال وهذا يعتبر تطور
للدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه عندما تستطيع
جزء من هذه الصواريخ وايضا للمره الاولى
روسيا تطلق ست صواريخ انجال على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه نعم شكرا لك من كيف متابعانا
الصحفي محمد البابا تحياتي محمد
مشاهدينا من المتوقع ان يلتقي وزير
الخارجي السعوديه الامير فيصل من فرحان
بنظيره الروسيس في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
حيث سيتم بحث جمله من القضايا بينها
العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين والازمه
الاوكرانيه هذا وكان وزير الخارجي السعودي
اكد في وقت سابق على امكانيه انهاء الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه بالمفاوضات
مشاهدينا هاتفيه تنضموا الينا من موسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتقام اهلا بك كاتيا نحن
كاتيا بانتظار مؤتمر صحفي لوزيري الخارجي
السعودي والروسي متى سيعقد هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي وابرز ما تمخض عن هذه الزياره حتى
الان
العربيه السعوديه بعد وصوله الى موسكو في
زياره رسميه فيلتقي او بدا اللقاء مع وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه وطبعا الملفات الرئيسيه
هي طبعا المصالح المشتركه بين البلدين
بالاضافه الى طبعا
تطرق الى الازمه الاوكرانيه وتاتي هذه
الزياره الوزير الخارجيه السعوديه بعد
زيارته الاخيره ايضا الى كياس طبعا بعد
اللقاء الان بعد ان بدا الاجتماع الان
توقع ان يكون هناك
امر صحفي للوزيرين
سيتحدثان بها الى الصحافه بعد انتهاء
الاجتماع حول نتائج طبعا الاجتماع الذي
معلومات اوفي عن اللقاءات التي عقدها
وسيعقدها وزير الخارجيه السعودي في موسكو
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نشرتنا مستمر وفيها بعد الفاصل
مشارعون امريكيون يدعون الى نهج جديد في
سياسه مواجهه ايران
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افاد مراس
العربي ان انتشارا كبيرا للشرطه
الاسرائيليه شهده محيط مطاري تل ابيب بسبب
احتجاجات مضيفا ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لن يدخل اسرائيل وسيجري لقاءاته في المطار
قبل ذلك قال مسؤولون امريكيون واسرائيليون
ان بل قالوا ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الى تعديل جدول الزياره المقرره اليوم
الخميس لاسرائيل وتغيير مكان انقاذ
الاجتماع في مصنع بالقرب من مطار اسرائيل
الدوري بناء على طلب وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه حيث سيلتقي اوستن رئيس
الوزراء بنا منظيره الاسرائيلي واوضح
المسؤولون ان التغيير طرا بسبب الاحتجاجات
المناهضه لحكومه نتنياهو التي من المتوقع
ان تشل حركه المرور في جميع انحاء البلاد
مع توقع اغلاق الطرق وتحذير من السلطات من
اضرابات محتمله في المطار
من مطار تلعب بمشاهدين تنضم الينا مراسل
العربيه لانا كولاسي اهلا بك لانا في
اجواء هذه الزياره زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لاسرائيل وما صاحبها ايضا من
ايرباك في جدول الزياره
اهلا بك صحيح يعني نحن نتحدث عن ايرباك في
الزياره كان من المتوقع ان يحضر فعليا الى
اسرائيل امس الاربعاء ولكن تم تغيير الخطه
الى سوف يقوم بالزياره اليوم الخميس فعليا
الان نحن نتواجد امام
المطار ولكن يعني لا يوجد هناك اغلاق الى
هذا المدخل الى حد الان ولكن بسبب
التوقعات باغلاق فعليا الطرق المؤديه الى
المطار الشرطه الاسرائيليه يعني اكدت بان
الزياره هذه ربما سوف تقوم سوف تكون
بالقرب من مطار بن غريون ولن تكون في
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وذلك حسب طلب
فعليا الجانب الاسرائيلي اما الان نحن
نتواجد امام فعليا المطار حيث من المتوقع
ان يغادر نتنياهو اليوم من هذا المطار الى
ايطاليا وفعليا هذا ما لا يريده
المتظاهرين حيث يعني صرحوا ليله امس بانهم
سوف يقوموا باغلاق الطرق المؤديه الى
المطار قاموا بتجنيد الاف المركبات حيث
سوف تسير بسرعه بطيئه في شارع يعني سريع
ويعني اكدوا بانهم سوف يسيرون بسرعه بطيئه
الاف السيارات سوف تقوم باغلاق الطريق
المؤديه الى المطار لمنع رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياه من التوجه الى ايطاليا
ولكن الشرطه الاسرائيليه ايضا قامت بالرد
على هذا التصريح وقالت بانها سوف تقوم
بتحرير مخالفات لكل مركبه تسير بشكل او
سرعه بطيئه في هذا الشارع السريع ومنذ
صباح اليوم يعني كان هناك حاله تاهب كبيره
في جميع مدن فعليا في جميع المدن هنا في
اسرائيل قامت ايضا الشرطه يعني بتعزيز
قواتها وكان هناك 3000 عنصر من الشرطه سوف
يتواجدون باكثر من مئه منطقه حيث يعني
تتوقع اسرائيل ان يكون هناك يعني متظاهرين
في هذه المواقع ومنذ صباح اليوم فعليا
شاهدنا الاف الاسرائيليين خرجوا في تل
ابيب قاموا باغلاق عدد من الطرق وايضا
يعني كان هناك جنود من الاحتياط في القدس
تحديدا قاموا ايضا بالتظاهر في مناطق من
القدس وستستمر هذه المظاهرات بدات منذ
صباح اليوم وستستمر حتى مساء هذا اليوم
ومن المتوقع ان يعني يشارك اكثر من 160
الف متظاهر في هذه المظاهرات اليوم هذه
صوره واضحه عن هذه الاحتجاجات لكن لو عدنا
مره اخرى الى ملف زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي هل توفرت معلومات حول الملفات
التي ستطرح في اجنده هذه الزياره
يعني العنوان الابرز فعليا هو الملف
النووي الايراني يعني
هو فعليا اكد بان الجانب الامريكي يعني هو
يساند ويقف جنبا الى جنب الى الجانب
الاسرائيلي لمنع لمنع ايران من حصولها على
السلاح النووي وهذا هو العنوان الابرز
لهذه الزياره هناك معلومات لذا لديه فعليا
سوف يقوم بمشاركتها مع مسؤولين في اسرائيل
وسوف يقومون يعني النقاش حول موضوع الملف
الايراني وهذا هو الملف الابرز جنبا ايضا
الى جنب موضوع الضفه الغربيه
يعني ما يحصل من اشتباكات من اعتقالات من
اغتيالات ايضا لعدد بناء الفلسطينيين
محاوله ايضا
لتهدئه او الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه المحت
له ايضا لهذه لصور من مناطق التظاهرات
المناهضه لحكومه نتنياهو شكرا لك من مطار
تل ابي كنت معنا مراست العربيه لانا
نعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا ونتابع هذه الصور
من
هذه الصور من تل ابيب الاحتجاجات التي
التي تنظمها جهات مختلفه معارضه لحكومه
هذه الاحتجاجات المناهضه للحكومه
خطه التغيير النظام القضائي التي تبنتها
حكومه نتنياهو التي توصف بالحكومه الاكثر
تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
كشف مسؤول الاسرائيلي كبير لموقع اكسياس
ان المحادثات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في البيت الابيض بشان ايران كانت
ايجابيه واظهرت ان الجانبي لديهما وجهه
نظر اكثر تطابقا وذلك في اعقاب الكشف عن
تقدم ايران في تخصيب اليورانيوم الى نسبه
84% وهو ما يقترب بنسبه المطلوبه لانتاج
قنبله هذا وكان البيت الابيض اكد في بيان
ان الفريق الامريكي بقياده مستشار الامن
القومي
الاسرائيلي استعرضوا بقلق كبير التقدم في
البرنامج النووي الايراني واضاف البيان
انه تم الاتفاقه على التعزيز التنسيق لمنع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي والتنسيق
لزياده ردع الانشطه الاقليميه العدائيه
لايران هذا وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
صرح ان بلاده انتظرت وقتا طويلا لكنها
الان ستقوم بكل ما يلزم لمنع ايران
بالامتلاك اسلحه نوويه
قتلت القوات الاسرائيليه ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين في بلده جبع جنوبي مخيم جنين
وافاد مراسو العربي ان القوات الاسرائيليه
اقتحمت البلده ونشرت القناصه على اسطح
المنازل بينما وقعت اشتباكات عنيفه
قوات خاصه
هاي السياره هونداي اكسنتاي
نزلوا من الباص
وام رام الله مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان اهلا بك عبد
الحفيظ واخر التحديثات حول الاوضاع
الامنيه في الضفه الغربيه
حاليا تجري عمليه تشييع الجثمين الشبان
الثلاثه في مدينه جنين وهم من كتيبه جنين
مقاتلين من كتيبه جنين يتبعون لسرايا
القدس وسط مشاركه كبيره الاف الفلسطينيين
يشاركون في عمليه التشييع وواسطه ايضا امر
لافت وهو القبر الجماعي مؤخرا بدات يعني
تنتشر ظاهره الكبور الجماعيه في مدينه
جنين وذلك بسبب عدم وجود وقت لحفر قبور
كثيره وبسبب ان اسرائيل اصبحت تقتل
الفلسطينيين باعداد يعني في كل اقتحام
لجنين اما سته او سبعه او ثلاثه وما الى
ذلك وبالتالي هذا يعجج غضب الفلسطينيين
بشكل كبير هناك هتافات داخل عمليه التشييع
اللي هي ضروره الرد اسرائيل تقول ان هؤلاء
الشبان الثلاثه كانوا يمثلون قنابل موقوته
بالنسبه للشباك الاسرائيلي وكانوا يعدون
لتنفيذ عمليات ضد اهداف اسرائيليه وبال
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه كانت قد رصدت تحركهم
من بلده جبع جنوب جنين باتجاه جنين وقامت
بالاشتباك معهم واغتيالهم ثلاثتهم اضافه
الى ذلك ايضا اعلنت وزاره الصحه ووفاه طفل
فلسطيني متاثرا بجراحه التي اصيب بها اول
امس خلال اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا
لمخيم الجنين وذلك الاقتحام الذي ادى
لمقتل سته فلسطينيين اضافه الى هذا الفتى
وزاره الصحه تقول ان اسرائيل قتلت اكثر 31
فلسطينيين في مدينه جنين منذ بدايه هذا
العام وذلك يرفع عدد الضحايا الفلسطينيين
الى 78 منذ بدايه هذا العام هذا بخصوص
الجنين هناك ايضا توتر في مختلف انحاء
الضفه الغربيه هذا التوتر ناتج اما على
الانتشار الكبير للقوات الاسرائيليه على
الحواجز وعمليات اقتحام الكره والمدن
لتنفيذ عمليات اعتقال او حتى اعتداءات
المستوطنين واخص تحديدا مدينه الخليل نشهد
منذ ايام اعتداءات المستوطنين على مواطنين
في منطقه تندرميده وسط مدينه الخليل ايضا
الان هناك توتر مثلا باب العمود في القدس
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اخلق اغلب اغلت المكان
وتقول ان هناك عثورا على جسم مشبوه في ذلك
المنطقه وتجري عمليات تفتيش وبالتالي بشكل
عام الامور متوتره واخذه في التصاعد شيئا
فشيئا هذا التوتر ايضا حفيظ وصل الى حدود
قطاع غزه هل توفت لك معلومات حول ما يحدث
هناك ايضا
حسب بيانات السلطه الفلسطينيه وكان يعني
هناك بيان من رئاسه الوزراء وصل قبل دقائق
يقول ان اسرائيل تشن حربا مفتوحه على
الفلسطينيين فقد تلبيه لرغبات طموح اليمين
واليمين المتطرف داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
في محاوله
لتنفيذ سياسه الترانزفير وسياسه تهجير
الفلسطينيين وقمع الفلسطينيين ويعني اجبار
الفلسطينيين للرضوخ للامر الواقع وتحمل
بيانات الحكومه الفلسطينيه ووزاره
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه المجتمع الدولي هذا
التصعيد الكبير وتطلب ايضا من الاداره
الامريكيه وبوجود وزير الدفاع في اسرائيل
ان تضغط على اسرائيل لوقف هذه العمليات
وخصوصا ان الاداره الامريكيه
ووزير الخارجيه كان قد وصل هنا قبل شهر
وتعهد للرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بان
يضغط على اسرائيل لوقف هذا التصعيد وكان
بعدها قمه العقبه ومشاركه فلسطينيه
واسرائيليه وكان يجب على الفلسطينيين ان
يشاهدوا نتائج تلك القمه ولكن النتائج
معكوسه حتى هذه اللحظه الميدانيا شكرا
الله كنت معنا مراسل عربي عبد الحفيظ تحيه
عبد الحفيظ
مشاهدينا ستعقد تركيا اليوم اجتماعا مع
السويد وفنلندا في العاصمه البلجيكيه
بروكسل وذلك لمناقشه التزامات دول شمال
اطلسي في محاولتهم الانضمام الى النيتو
وسيحضر اجتماع الاليه المتشكله في اطار
المذكره الثلاثيه بين تركيا او فنلندا
والسويد من الجانب التركي المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم جالين ونائب وزير
الخارجيه المعين حديثا بوراك
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
تحت ضغط الشارع واحتياجات العنيفه
يسحب قانون الوكالات الاجانب
مقتل حاكم ولايه بلق الشماليه افغانستان
في انفجار ضخم استهدف اجتماعا داخل مقره
هجوم صاروخي يستهدف عده مدن اوكرانيه
ويخرج محطه زابوريجيا عن الخدمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات اسرائيل تمنع من دخول تل ابيب
وسيجيل لقاءاته خارج المدينه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم بلده جامع جنوب
مخيم جنين وتقتل ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلان الحزب
الحاكم في جورجيا سحب مشروع قانون مثير
للجدل يهدد عمل وسائل اعلامي والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه جاء ذلك بعد موجه من
الاحتياجات اخرها يوم امس حينما استخدمت
الشرطه خراطيم المياه في محاوله لتفريغ
المتظاهرين الذين احتشدوا بالقرب من مبنى
البرلمان في تبنيس اعتراضا على القانون
هذا واتهم رئيس لجنه التشريع الدستوري
بمجلس الاتحاد الروسي اندريكليشاس اتهام
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
بمحاوله تنفيذ انقلاب غير دستوري في
جورجيا تصريحك جاء على قناته على
التليجرام حيث تعتبر ان قرار الانقلاب
الذي وصفه بالمدبر هو رد على محاوله
جورجيا فهم ما يحدث في اطار التمويل
الاجنبي العديد من المنظمات غير الحكوميه
على اراضيها وفق قولها
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك حذف المتحدث باسم الخارج
الامريكيه حكومه جورجيا على احترام حريه
التجمع السلمي والاحتجاجات السلميه ودعا
جميع الاطراف الى ممارسته ضبط النفس وتجنب
اي اعمال تصعيديه او عنيفه
نحث حكومه جورجيا على احترام حريه التجمع
السلمي والاحتجاجات السلميه وندعو جميع
الاطراف على ممارسه ضبط النفس وتجنب اي
اعمال تصعيديه او عنيفه مع احترام سياده
القانون والقيم الديمقراطيه في جورجيا
اصدرت عشرات النشطات الايرانيات في مجال
حقوق المراه بيانا ادنى فيهما وصفا ما
وصفناه بالتسميد المتعمد والمتسلسل
للطالبات في المدارس ودعت الناشطات في
بيانهن الى عزل او اقاله وزيري التربيه
والتعليم والصحه لفشلهما في حمايه حياه
وصحه الالاف من الطالبات وطالبه الناشطات
بتشكيل خليه ازمه عاجله بمشاركه اطباء
ومحامين مستقلين وعدد من اسر الطالبات
اضافه الى متخصصين تابعوا عن كثب هذه
الماساه الانسانيه وشددنا على ظهوره تشكيل
هذه اللجنه بدعم كامل بمنظمه الصحه
العالميه وصلب الاحمر واطباء بلا حدود
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اي
تعطل طويل الامد تدفق المساعده الانسانيه
الى سوريا سيكون مصدر قلق لها وذلك بعد
خروج مطار حلب عين خدمه بسبب ضربه جويه
القت وسائل اعلام سوريا باللوم فيها على
اسرائيل وكان المطار يستخدم للمساعده في
توصيل المساعده المتضررين جراء زلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا الشهر
الماضي متابعه
نشعر بالقلق اذا اثار اي اغلاق مطول على
تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه الى المحتاجين
لقد كان مطار حلب بمثابه نقطه هبوط
للمساعدات الانسانيه لاولئك الذين تضرروا
في سوريا من هذا الزلزال المدمر واي اغلاق
مطول للمطار سيكون ذلك مصدر قلق كبير لنا
قال رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان مسؤولين
والصحفيين قاموا بتاويل تصريحاته بشان
الهجره حسب اهوائهم لالحاق الضرر بتونس
واضاف سعيد انه دعا فقط الى احترام
القانون التونسي والشرعيه والسياده
دعا الرئيس الصيني الى الارتقاء بسرعه
اكبر بالقوات المسلحه وتحديثها الى مستوى
عالمي وقال شيك كلمه امام البرلمان انه
يجب على الصين تعظيم قدراتها الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه وتحسين القوه الشامله للبلاد بشكل
منهجي للتعامل مع المخاطر الاستراتيجيه
تاتي هذه التصريحات في ظل تصعيد امريكي
صيني كبير بشان قضيه تايوان
اطلق الشرطه مكافحه الشغب التركيه مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق مجموعه من المتظاهرين
تشاجروا مع قوات الشرطه في نهايه مسيره
للاحتفال بيوم المراه العالمي وست اسطنبول
يوم المراه العالمي مسحوق الفلفل بالتفريق
المتظاهرات في تركيا
[موسيقى]
شرطه مكافحه الشغب التركيه اطلقت مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق نحو 2000 امراه في وسط
اسطنبول
السلطات المحليه كانت قد منع التنظيم اي
مسيره او احتجاجات او بيانات صحفيه في وسط
المدينه
التركيات اثناء محاولتهن دفع دروع الشرطه
دعينا الى استقاله الحكومه
المتظاهرات هتفنا لن نسكت ولسنا خائفات
ولا ننحني
الاشتباكات مع الشرطه تاتي قبل اكثر من
شهرين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه التركيه
سفيره ليوم واحد تحت هذا العنوان اطلقت
السفاره البريطانيه في بيروت مبادره
للاحتفال بيوم المراه شاركت فيها 9 سفارات
وثلاث منظمات دوريه وتم اختيار اثنتي عشره
فتاه لعبنا دور سفراء وامضوا يوما بل يوم
عمل معهم وهدفت المبادره الى تعزيز ثقه
الشابات وتدريبهن على العمل الدبلوماسي
رغم ان عمرها لا يتعدل 15 عاما الا ان
الجانب في الامضه يوم عمل كامل مع سفير
بريطانيا في لبنان فهي ايضا سفيره ولكن
لاربع وعشرين ساعه فقط في مبادره لتكريم
المراه خلال يومها العالمي
رافقت الجنيفر السفيره الى مؤسسات انسانيه
ومقرات حكوميه بعد اختيارها من اصل 500
فتاه شاركنا في مسابقه تمحورت حول افكار
لانشاء مجتمع عادل في تجربه حلوه اول شيء
ما خبرت انه شاركت بس وقتها اتصلوا فيا
خبرتها وكان كتير فخوره
انه في عالم انه عنجد بيهتموا كان عنا
وشفت انه
هي واحده من 12 فتاه تتراوح اعمارهن بين
الخمسه عشر والثمانيه عشر عاما رافقنا
سفارات تسعه دول بينها الولايات المتحده
واسبانيا واستراليا وكندا والاردن اضافه
الى ممثلين عن ثلاث منظمات دوليه
سعدنا بوجود جينيفر كسفيره اليوم هذا جزء
من مهام متعدده نقوم بها في لبنان والعالم
لمسانده حقوق النساء يوم جنيفر كان حافلا
لان يوم السفير يكون عاده مليء بالانشطه
زرنا وزير البيئه ومؤسسه الهادي لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه التي تدعمها السفاره
البريطانيه بعد لقاء بالشابات اعتقد ان
مستقبل لبنان بايد امينه
المبادره التي اطلقتها السفاره البريطانيه
تهدف الى تعزيز الثقه الشابات بانفسهن
وتدريبهن على اسس العمل الدبلوماسي الذي
قد يفتح الباب امام غد افضل في شهر المراه
العالمي توحدت السفارات حول المراه
اللبنانيه واهميه دعم فتيات سيكون مرحله
التغيير في المستقبل غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت
كشف موقع اكسس الامريكيه عن مناقشات واسعه
النطاق بين اعضاء من الحزب الجمهوري
والديمقراطي هدفها ايجاد تشريع يضبط مساله
الوثائق السريه في نهايه الاداره الرئاسيه
والعديد من النقاط المتعلقه بعائلات
الرؤساء نتابع تفاصيل في هذا التقرير
في امريكا تحركات جمهوريه وديمقراطيه
هدفها ايجاد تشريع يضبط مساله الوثائق
السريه في نهايه الاداره الرئاسيه ويصلح
عمليات الارشيف الوطنيه تقرير نشره موقع
اكسيوس كشف عن تشريعات يحتمل ان تكون
حزبيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي تقف وراءها
اطراف من عائلتي
حيث يسعى كبار قاده لجنه الرقابه بمجلس
النواب الى تحويل العداوات الحزبيه
الشديده بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين الى
اصلاحات تندرج كلها ضمن تشريع حقيقي يتعلق
بالوثائق السريه وشؤون الاسره الرئاسيه
غير ان بعض القاده الديمقراطيين يرون انه
لا يوجد اي سبب لفرض افشاء المعلومات من
افراد الاسره الذين هم مواطنون عاديون لكن
الامر قد يكون مختلفا بخصوص الوظائف
الفيدراليه في اشاره الى جارد كوشنر
وايفانكا ترامب
الديمقراطيون وفق ما نشره موقع اكسيوس
اشتكوا من قيام الاداره السابقه وافراد
الاسره باشياء تتجاوز الحدود والتي تسببت
في مشكله هيكليه اثرت على السياسه
الامريكيه في السنوات الاخيره
فلطالما كانت الاسئله الاخلاقيه
والقانونيه حول عائله ترامب واعماله
واستثماراته الاجنبيه مصدر تحقيق وانتقاد
من الديمقراطيين موقع اكسيوس اشار ايضا
الى مناقشات واسعه النطاق بين اعضاء من
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي والتي جاءت
بالتزامن مع الجهود المكثفه التي يبذلها
موظفون لجنه الرقابه في سبيل ايجاد تشريع
يطالب بمزيد من الافصاح المالي من افراد
الاسره الرئاسيه
الاخباريه مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز العناوين
مقتل حاكم ولايه بلغا الشماليه افغانستان
في انفجار ضخم استهدف اجتماعا داخل مقره
هجوم الصاروخي يستهدف عده مدن اوكرانيه
ويخرج محطه زابوريجيا عن الخدمه
احتياجات اسرائيل تمنع من دخول تل ابيب
وسيجري لقاءاته خارج المدينه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم بلده التجمع
الجنوبيه مخيم جنين وتقتل ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين
حيث
[موسيقى]